kohei arihara fared well in his first
outing unfortunately didn't get the win
in that situation but another chance at
it here tonight chris woodward very
pleased with his debut for san diego
trent grisham the fort worth native will
lead off and play center he's just off
the injured list today his first game of
the year
and he got him swinging so grisham
strikes out and we're underway
start number two in a padres uniform for
joe musgrove
jabba joe on the hill into the heart of
texas
here's anderson tejeda for his first
at-bat of 20-21 just called up today
brock holt on the injured list with a
streamed hamstring one and two curve
ball right down the middle strike three
called punched about one uh two away
next up joey gallo
here's the 2-2 pitch swinging amaze got
him to go chasing the change up down and
back-to-back strikeouts for joe musgrove
to end a one-two-three first inning will
myers coming up
runner on first nobody out scoreless in
a second and meyer strokes this one
towards the left field corner and he'll
get down for a base hit maybe extra
bases white has a hard time playing it
in the left field corner osmer's
rounding third going to try and score
here comes the relay to the plate and he
is safe
looked like the catcher trevino had
forced him away from the plate
but haaz must have gotten the hand in
there and slapped on holm
immediately the bench coach for the
rangers don wakamatsu is on the
clubhouse phone to see if they want to
challenge this
is there going to be enough to overturn
might not be
this may go the padres way hold all
tickets
let's see
oh my
not enough to overturn it apparently
rbi double for will myers one nothing
padres and now tommy pham batting
seventh
coming to flat
a 3-1 pitch to tommy fan
jolts this one out towards deep right
center field tavares going back under
the dirt of the track to make the catch
right in front of the wall and then on
the transfer he drops the baseball
meyers is coming around from second base
to score the second padres run the
padres will take a two nothing lead
tommy pham is out but the ball dropped
out there by tavares
what a huge break for the padres
what a weird play that was tomorrow's
going back makes the catch look like
when he was going into the glove it
flips out of his glove a long way away
all right he's able to take off and
score from second base caratina the
ninth place hitter for san diego 308
average to start the year and we touched
on it briefly as we opened the broadcast
one of many new faces this year ground
ball right side
back on it a little ways solar sort of
thirds want to stretch it first by
guzman
and they get carrotini
wow
amazing work there from ronald guzman
there are not too many first baseman in
the game that make this play absolutely
tremendous
and manny machado coming up
this one is line towards the gap in left
center it's going to get down
grisham will score the third padres run
manny machado to second base with an rbi
double
and the padres lead it three to nothing
big two out rbi for machado
manny machado really taking care of a
mistake big-time mistake at 89 out of
the hand of arie harla
oh it had that good sound as well
right up the alley
and eric hosmer stands in 3-2 pitch on
the way swinging a hard-hit ball knocked
down by guzman the ball goes in foul
ground he picks it up flips to arahar
recovering and he beats hosner to the
bag nice job on that smash
by guzman to just knock it down and keep
it closer that he could make a play
so fam on first
and myers on third for the number eight
batter ha sung kim
grounded out his first time
here's the 1-0 swinging a ground ball
two-third coming up with it to hate it
to second for one on the first and they
get them both this time five to four to
three
and uh the padres will not score here in
the fourth no runs two hits one left
three and a half complete it remains
three nothing san diego
and there is one away for ronald guzman
trevino the batter struck out looking
his first timer
first pitch swing ground ball shortstop
kim's got it throw to first trevino is
out and another one two three inning for
joe musgrove who is through five no hit
no run innings padres three and the
rangers nothing
joe retired the first 11 in a row before
hitting joey gallo
and he has now set down six straight
since then
talked about the emotion that musgrove
pitches with
carrotini is giving a palm like calm
down you're okay one two fastball right
down the middle and strike three called
another one two three inning for joe
musgrove and he caps it with a k
six shutout innings no hits allowed and
eight strikeouts anderson to haida a
switch hitter we'll see him for the
third time he has struck out twice one
two swinging a miss got him with a
slider in the dirt and for the third
time tonight tahedah strikes out nine
for joe musgrove
1-0
and gallo swings hits a hard grounder
right to first base pro far down to and
he has it brings it to first two away in
the bottom of the seventh inning
two outs and the base is empty
the 3-2 to low is swung on and missed
strength three a slider running into the
left-handed hitter 10 strikeouts for joe
musgrove and another one two three
inning no runs no hits again and we go
to the eighth three to nothing san diego
camillo pagan is now throwing in the
padre bullpen
two and two solak waits the pitch from
musgrove is grounded to shortstop hassan
kim has it throw to first in time and
one away in the bottom of the eighth
inning
now 22 of 23 on the night retired by joe
muscaro first pitch swing and a ground
ball to first pro far down to two knees
has it flipped to muscular covering and
two outs in the bottom of the eighth
smell it
joe he wants to get to that finish line
[Applause]
heavily on the mind of jace tingler no
doubt
a ball in two strikes again to jose
trevino the pitch is lined to right
field myers charging he makes the catch
and joe musgrove is through eight no run
no hit innings this is one heck of a
script right here going on before our
very eyes
kit from el cajon
pitching in little league in san diego
grossmont high school
[Applause]
hometown kid he's got san diego on his
chest
here's the 1-1 and that is line at
cronin worth and caught one away
oh and two the pitch is reached forward
tapped slowly to the right of the mound
musgrove has it he will tag tavares
himself two outs in the bottom of the
night well ladies and gentlemen
it's destiny and joe
[Applause]
grab all the shortstop kim will go to
first the san diego
get their first now hitter in the
history of the franchise and it belongs
to san diego's own joe musgrove sending
the friar faithful into a frenzy